Before we get going
with our discussion
of inference
methods, it is worth
looking at the big picture
for some perspective.
So far, we have
concentrated on ways
to analyze probability models.
This part of the picture.
If our model has been
selected in a careful way,
then it should also be
relevant to the real world
and help us make
predictions or decisions.
But how do we know
that this is the case?
This is why we need to look
at data that are generated
by the real world, and then use
these to come up with a model.
This is what the field of
inference and statistics
is all about.
This field has undergone
a radical transformation
in recent years.
I will exaggerate a
little, but in the past,
a statistician might
be called to look
at problems such as this one.
You're given data
on a few patients,
and you need to figure out
whether a certain treatment is
effective or not.
But today, a statistician
lives in a dreamland.
There are tons of data that
are generated everywhere.
These allow us to build quite
detailed large models involving
thousands of parameters.
And we do have the computational
power to do all that.
In this landscape,
the opportunities
for a statistician are endless.
So let me give you a small
representative sample.
In a somewhat
traditional setting,
one designs a data
collection method,
and then uses these data to
make a simple prediction.
This is the case, for
example, in polling.
Where the purpose is to predict
the outcome of an election.
Another field is
marketing and advertising,
where the situation
is somewhat similar.
Except now, we want
to make predictions
not for a population
as a whole, but
for each individual consumer.
And a particular
application has to do
with so-called
recommendation systems.
You collect ratings that
people give to movies, as
in a famous competition that
was announced by Netflix.
So you have data for
every movie and the people
who have watched them.
You make a note of
what rating that person
gave to a particular movie.
And now after you collect huge
amounts of data of this kind,
you try to use this
information to guess
whether, for example,
this person is
interested in this
particular movie or not.
This is a quite
difficult problem.
A quite complicated one.
And it gave the
community an opportunity
to develop fancier and fancier
combinations of methods
in order to come up
with good predictions
of unknown entries
in this table.
Another field is,
of course, finance.
The markets are truly uncertain.
And there are quite
complete historical data.
Lots of them.
How do we use these data
to make predictions?
Coming now to the
natural sciences,
a revolution has been taking
place in the life sciences.
There are tons of genomic data
to be processed to find out
what combination of genes
causes what disease.
Or we may want to
find out the details
of the chemical reactions
inside a living cell.
And there is an upcoming
new frontier, neuroscience,
where there will be vast amounts
of data that will be generated.
These will consist of
brain measurements.
Of measurements of what
each neuron is doing.
And hopefully, these
will lead us one day
to finding out what the brain
really does and how it works.
In the sciences,
the list is endless.
It goes on and on.
In modeling climate
and the environment,
scientists are using a
huge models these days.
Which they try to calibrate
using lots of available data.
And in physics as
well, scientists
to use fancy inference
methods trying to find
needles in a haystack.
Like rare particles
or remote planets.
Finally, engineering is
a fight against noise.
Engineers try to
make devices that
will work in uncertain
environments.
The field of signal
processing is a prime example
where the generic
question is to recover
the content of a signal.
For example, the content
of a radio transmission
when a signal is received after
it gets corrupted by noise.
I could go on and on for hours
generating lists of this kind,
but we have to stop somewhere.
The bottom line is that the
opportunities and the needs
are vast.
For this reason, we will look
into the core methodologies
that come into play.
Fortunately for us, the
fundamental concepts
and approaches turn out
to be the same independent
of the particular application.